shock returning to the lineup after missing the
last seven games there's laer the overtime hero
on Monday out him TOS off the goal post
and some good Pace here to start and this
feet from here's trouba with the puck up the
middle off the skate of M now Zan and with a
shot C the side by vasileski good job there
by zaban be able to get that shot off after
avoiding the contact from [Applause] headman
here's Conor Sherry for the lightning turned
aside by quick two shifts two huge hits excited
with his return to the lineup now Point thr the
puck in front and in quick was able to extend
poer M sending it back out Victor headen with
room Fires at the flex wide radish cares in deep
centering pass with a shot save by quick comes
away with the Pu Sher got a chance to right on
in front of quick couple of beautiful passing
plays there by the lightning Hitler and headon
came together behind the net Sherry on the par
big hit behind the play by kie on bot by former
Ranger twice quick covers up heel gave a little
stick to kie as he was heading off the X as
well just checking in to see how everybody's
Allstar break wi brought by true but that Plum
by bki look you got to make that decision right
away uh and if you don't boost then what then
just hang in the net and play the breakway if
he gets with and hope maybe your Defender can get
to the puck brought by cono radish with the puck
for Tampa bank or not with the way it's gone for
sure yeah you don't you don't know but coaches
are playing a percentages in analytics there
up by points that's GL by Jonathan quck there
you go Ken pretty good period for Tampa Bay bu
considering how long they've been off yeah their
energy is there and not easy to do right when
you have that long layoff you wonder how teams
are going to come out who from we spoke with pet
AV L earlier very impressed with what he's seen
from Ryan Linden L his first season as Racers
head coach I can feel it trust me even though
I'm down here I know I can feel the daggers check
your text right now I was firing off a text it's
the way they do it nowadays here's kov off the
bounce oh what a shot that was skate shoot right
and lightning remains scoreless COV came close
to getting 11 days and now the back to back iers
tomorrow here's L gr back out got this the N sto
by veski dson with the initial attempt now prider
between the circles Far Side dson Sav vasileski
again he he doesn't allow any goals through his
body and and this year we've seen more goals
through him a little bit we have to watch out
here oh oh yeah good save there by quick is Stam
Co who's had himself a heck of a night so far goes
to the back end there was some room up top but
he wasn't able to elevate that puck we'll say
with Goal tending here uh you a long time you've
been with Ben wildair right Jonathan Quick he's
one of the most aggressive goal tenders we've seen
in the NHL for a long time how do you think that
relationship or that marriage has been between
the way Benny has a philosophy of playing goal
tending and the way that quick plays here in
New York well watching quaky play this year I
do feel like he took a step back a little bit
he's one of the best goals in the league east
to west oh here we got a goal Tak it away H for
play by play Jimmy play Jimmy VY my old teammate
wow liy Bey gives the Rangers a one nothing lead
and then back the other way backhand again baseski
oh boy looked like he might have been cheating
I'll let you guys talk about the golender but
from a scor's point of view looked like he was
cheating over oh yeah he definitely plays the
pass you can even see his stick try to cover
that pass going across so he's not ready for
that backend shot and Jimmy Visa takes advantage
if he plays that again I suspect you would have
played that a little differently you probably
would have done a VH there right with the glove
up in that situation well I was just thinking when
I saw that play V is you very good at keeping that
glove High not at display but yeah me personally
I always try to keep that glove High you remember
that how skilled they are take deep a there a few
teams that are looking for goalies any interest
or I wish I could I've been playing a couple on
night games here lately they scored another one
so Michael Leighton actually ended up with the
goalie of record and got the win so did did lvy
mention that to you earlier today yeah he did
that's what I thought y now Hank you guys were
talking about the Advantage Rangers as we touched
on earlier in the game considering they played the
other night for air for p back across oh what
a stop left Save On laier by vasilki is vassie
anderon to left frenier and vasileski flashing
the leather the Tampa bone good play look there
really nice play Schneider lerberg from Norway
the ninth Norwegian to play in that after Hockey
leag Star ripski two nothing Rangers this Puck
finds a hole on vasileski don't think he would
scream the quick play in the corner with wheeler
and the slot area Ryder's going to get it and he
throws it right out to bronin I don't know
BR is this is chernack screening him at all
no he not right he just finds a hole you know
what it is edzo when that Puck's in the corner
as a goenda you you go a little sleepy you think
everything's under control that there really is no
danger how just on top of everything they were
in that first period and we mentioned it at some
point they're going to hit a wall and they hit
a wall in a second and they're still trying to
get away from that wall here in the third score
Hegel on the setup from chck and the lightning
are on the B is now two to one oh they got away
from the wall and they beat Jonathan Quick and
now they've got some energy and they've got
some jump hegel's going to get this puug out
in front of him right part of your screen coer
off to chernack and then Hegel gets it backhand
forehand and then just fire an absolute Dart
to the stick side on Jonathan Quick this is
what happens when you have a team that doesn't
give up possession in Tampa kucherov hangs on
to the puck outside the blue line he's not going
to dump the puck in brazinski made it two nothing
yeah brazinski playing on that third line C off
nice move backand shot stopped by Qui oh what a
move there hitting that puck on his backand and
getting it to the net and then there you see the
move by coov here's COV with 840 on the clock
shot was blocked by linr here comes paner now
throw check a and a save by vasilki laier extend
the lead off the rush Alexi lafier the feed from
put it out by thean g a step on lber thean CR eyes
paner Stu by [Applause] vasi guys fire this Puck
along the Ice Park cleared by wi I would keep an
eye on here is if there's a whistle at all 30 540
a minute in Tampa's got a timeout there so keep
an eye on that here moving forward d by head off
the go post but they did have a chance off the
rush hadman the surprise slapper from distance
play by LR surrounded by three lightning
players P comes the good R has Dy ahead of
him Dey Racing for the PT that is empty Kimmy
VY scores his second of the game into an empty
well that should do it far Boule and then the
play on the wall by goodro and vzy puts As Time
wipes down par of the net as the horn sounds
look like it may have been a bit too late